unmasking the latest round of covet
hypocrites
with critics slamming these top
democrats as dr fauci defends the new
cdc mask
guidance for the vaccinated watch
the fact is there are things that are
individual responsibilities
that one has and there are things that
have to do with you
individually which also impact
others if you get infected even if you
are without symptoms
you very well may infect another person
who may be vulnerable who may get
seriously ill
so in essence you are encroaching on
their
individual rights
this is outnumbered i'm emily compagno
and here today my co-host kaylee
mcinerney
host of kennedy on fox business kennedy
host of no interruption on fox nation
tommy larin
and in the center virtual seat lawrence
jones fox and friends enterprise
reporter and
fox news political analyst now the mayor
of dc is kicking off the hypocrisy hit
parade
as democrat muriel bowser was seen
maskless at a wedding
after reinstating the city's mass
mandate her chicago counterpart mayor
laurie lightfoot
also seen maskless rubbing elbows with
celebrities amid the massive crowds at
lollapalooza
this as she's also facing criticism for
even allowing that massive outdoor music
festival at all
and then there's former president obama
who is reportedly defying cdc guidance
for his upcoming 60th birthday bash
inviting nearly 500 guests to his
martha's vineyard mansion
all while covet cases are rising
nationwide and president biden says more
restrictions could soon be on the way
meantime nancy pelosi who just
reinstated reinstated the mass mandate
in the house
is directing capitol police to arrest
those who refuse to wear one
and she seemed to flout her own rules
just days later
lawrence welcome back to the show this
pattern is
exhausting we are now 17 months
into what has been a pandemic and these
fluctuations of mass mandates and not
with these democratic leaders continuing
to behave like this to to flout their
own
mandates that they set in broad daylight
yeah emily it's great to be here with
all you ladies um
you know i have no problem with these
elected officials living their life
hell that's what the majority of
americans are saying right now just let
us live our life
let's let's move on from this we it's
over a year now let's get back to some
normalcy
the problem is is that they've been
telling the public that they can't do
that
and you know at first i thought look the
mask and all of these measures were
maybe a security blanket kova did break
a lot of people
especially mentally a lot of people are
still recovering from that
and so i thought it was that measure
that we should judge them by but they
don't believe in any of this nonsense
because we
we know for a fact now that the rules
that they're placing for others
they're not following them themselves
and
i would caution our leaders to look
around the world look at places like
france
where there is massive protests going on
where people are saying they're
they rejected they reject what
government is doing they're sick of it
and it's only a matter of time before
those type of protests
come to the united states we saw the
same thing with cuba people are talking
about
freedom and they rejected socialism and
they don't like the outcomes
of that americans should be aware of
this
as well as our our leaders as well but i
think there is
a hidden agenda in this and i think that
that they don't want to release the
control
uh i think this is just another way for
government to become
daddy again um and we know where this
ends
at the end of the day but i don't see a
shift from the democratic party
they also want to use some of these
measures to continue uh
the election uh the way it was this past
year some of these safety measures they
were put in place
they're able to pass hr1 if they say
look guys
you know we're still in a pandemic type
environment so
we need more drive-through voting we
need more mailing voting i just think
that at the end of the day as much as i
want to
say that they have good will there's
always a end goal with the democrats
right and kennedy to lawrence's points
you know as as certain rights and
liberties became constricted and people
were willing
to do so for the good of public health
that's now been washed away by this
totally confusing mixed messaging
and the hypocrisy on these leaders part
they fail to demonstrate then that type
of
importance even as the delta variant is
warming its way through the country
when americans couldn't rely on some
type of clear messaging they have
nothing
to go on from these people so why should
any of them expect compliance
no and that's who they should be looking
to the politicians that they
right now almost completely distrust
and their actions betray their beliefs
they believe
that the virus is not deadly or at least
the virus is very political and isn't
going to infect
democrats so whatever standards they
have for their own personal lives
and who they go out and see and hobnob
with
those are the standards that we should
have and it's
it's much better for politicians to say
uh you have to be the one
in charge of your own decisions you know
in instead of
these blanket mandates that end up
hurting you know the the people who need
the most liberty and the most
opportunity right now uh they're the
ones that are hamstrung by
this hypocrisy so whatever they're doing
that's the new uniform set of standards
so
we can go to weddings we can go to
concerts we can have parties we can be
unmasked because they did they're the
ones with the data
and they're the ones with the control
right lead by example tommy and to
kennedy's point about blanket mask
mandates
what we are seeing however is just a
stick otherwise not only are they
failing to comply with it but there's a
massive stick
speaker pelosi threatening with arrest
using capital police
as a stick for her fellow congressmen if
they fail to wear a mask while
vaccinated yeah you can loot a target or
a foot locker you can have a mass
shoplifting and the democrats don't bat
an eyelash but if you don't wear your
mask or as i call it your face diaper
the nancy pelosi is going to come after
you
but you know i agree with my fellow
panelists here i'm not upset
at these democratic mayors or any
democrats at all for
exercising their rights for living their
lives that's what we should be doing at
this point
at the beginning we were told we had to
flatten the curve and if we ever
fall for that again we are morons and we
are sheep now the first time we didn't
know what was going on
we didn't know how to control this
pandemic it has been over a year and a
half now
we have accepted the fact that covet is
not going to be eradicated anytime soon
we have to be safe
we have to be responsible we have to
protect the most vulnerable
we also have to live our lives and as
lawrence pointed to
once democrats and once tyrants and
wannabe dictators
once they gain control once they start
convincing you to give up your rights
you won't likely get them back and
that's what we're seeing now they dangle
the carrot in front of your face first
it was if you get vaccinated then you
don't have to wear a mask and then they
took that away
now they're saying even if you're
vaccinated you have to wear a mask and
americans are sitting around wondering
what is next and i know that there are a
lot of business owners as well
that are sitting there clenching their
teeth very concerned that we're going to
have more lockdowns
more shutdowns then that's going to lead
to more of this unemployment people
collecting money not being able to
get them to return to work this is a
slippery slope and lawrence is exactly
right there weaponizing this they
weaponize fear every single time
and i believe they have their eyes set
on the midterm elections to pull the
same thing
that they did in 2020 with mass mail in
voting through coveted fear
and kaley tommy talks about once a right
is extinguished or surrendered it's
really difficult to get it back
and we heard in the intro dr fauci
saying that failing to wear a mask
is quote encroaching on others
individual rights
right uh he might not know what
individual rights are i can
share that with him the first amendment
your right to go to church your right to
worship
your god your right to political speech
these are individual rights
not someone else's right uh being
infringed upon because your failure to
wear a mask
perhaps he needs to go study individual
rights that being said let me just
address the fact that with muriel bowser
this is not her first offense at
hypocrisy do you remember she took the
train to delaware or she traveled to
delaware rather i don't know if it was
by train or plane
to go to a biden victory party despite
her own city's regulation about not
traveling to high areas
of coven 19 she violated that lightfoot
once again this is her
second offense because remember remember
she went to go get that haircut
and when asked about that haircut when
others couldn't go receive a haircut she
said well i'm the public face
of the city and that is the root of the
problem they say to you
in the middle of a pandemic you can't go
to church your kids can't go to school
your child must wear a mask but i'll go
to french laundry in california
you know i'll if i'm barack obama i have
hundreds of people at my house at my
lavish
martha's vineyard mansion but you don't
go to school
you don't go to church different rules
for you than for me and this all comes
down i'll never forget being in the
trump administration every time there
was a trump rally
it was a super spreader event but the
blm protest
a thousand public health officials came
out and said quote however as public
health advocates we do not condemn these
gatherings
as risky for covid19 transmission once
again
one standard for the trump rally another
standard for the blm protests
americans see the hypocrisy right
but for a year and a half we have been
seeing this pattern of hypocrisy
it is exhausting and it has eroded any
credibility
that these guys have for setting these
mandates no wonder everyone's ignoring
it